contrairement à ce qu'a dit geoffrey
lejeune tout à l'heure et chose sur
laquelle j'avais absolument envie de
rebondir
cette haine anti musulman où ce rejet de
la communauté musulmane en france il ne
se ne se ressent pas dans les
statistiques que tu as grandi du
ministère de l'intérieur
elle se ressent dans quelque chose de
beaucoup plus l'attend et pernicieux
comme les discriminations à l'embauché
les descriminations lors de l'accès au
logement les discriminations que te font
subir ton nom musulman ou à consonance
musulmane on parle de cette haine et de
ce projet là en particulier j'avais une
question pour vous monsieur mélenchon je
pense que c'est bien que vous puissiez
éclaircir ce point votre position sur
les femmes qui portent le voile leur
droit à porter le voile ce que ça
représente pour vous aujourd'hui parce
que votre position à plus ou moins
changé sur le sujet alors ça c'est
important qu'on le sache que c'est vrai
que ça s'est tiré que c'était c'était le
sujet je voulais aborder maintenant
après cette loi qu'est ce que vous dites
là dessus alors sur quoi parce qu'il
faut bien le port du voile alors que son
père une chose ça vous connaissez mon
âge et 69 ans mais donc j'ai traversé ou
une vie en voyant des situations
complètement différente
quant aux liens de l'arménie rapatrier
traversé la méditerranée aussi ouais
c'est ça donc quand on a été rapatrié en
france en 62 j'ai quitté un pays où
toutes les femmes avaient un voile sur
le visage et je suis arrivé dans un pays
où aucune n'en avait dans ma famille on
attelle ancienne tradition pas musulmane
catholique ma famille et catholiques ont
les femmes n'étaient pas en cheveux ça
se faisait pas oh mais tu es en foulard
j'ai des photos il ya ma grand mère ma
mère ma soeur tout le monde à un foulard
sur la tête à vous les savez roulant de
france terminé il ya plus de tout ça
trop le temps passe c'était pas un
problème c'était pas un sujet peu pour
moi tout d'un coup
alors vous vous en êtes pas rendu comme
vous êtes né dedans mais pas moi tout
d'un coup revoilà dévoile sur les têtes
des gens alors au début je dis les
choses franchement j'étais très choquée
parce que j'étais pas d'accord et je dis
que sur le plan personnel je suis
toujours pas d'accord mais je prends pas
mes désirs ou mes émotions personnelles
pour la loi
que doit-on dire dans le service public
c'est à dire les fonctionnaires qui sont
derrière un guichet et c'est pas de
trace d'appartenance religieuse que ce
soit une kippa une grosse croix ou
foulard ou tout ce que vous voulez rien
tout le monde doit se sentir à l'aise
parce que tout le monde est propriétaire
en commun du service public
après dans la rue mais l'espace il est
public
donc les gens s'habillent comme ils
veulent alors on me dit oui mais alors
il ya des pays où il ya des gens qui
vont en prison parce que ils veulent pas
parce que ils portent pas le voile mais
alors justement faisons pas pareil on va
pas faire la police du vêtement et
courir après les gens dans la rue pour
leur enlever le voile qu'ils ont sur la
tête en ce moment déjà en maître c'est
l'espace public il s'habille comme ils
veulent vous je vous préviens à tous les
gens écoutez moi bien vous ne vous en
sortirez pas si vous commencez à décider
comment les femmes ont droit de
s'habiller
vous ne vous en sortirez pas d'ailleurs
à l'assemblée nationale la rigolade a
lieu parce que quand on a décidé qu'on
porterait plus la cravate alors un
nirvana la cravate vous êtes obligé faut
respecter les gens peut comprendre ça
moi mes copains et c'est surtout les
filles qui étaient à fond contre la
cravate bon alors au bureau de
l'assemblée nationale il commence à dire
ah bah non il va falloir mettre la
cravate libre ou très bien au quai en
remettre à la cravate et les chaussettes
si vous voulez mais et nos collègues
féminines vous avez l'intention leur
dire comment elles doivent s'appeler
tout le monde a changé de tête c'est
impossible
comment elles vont samy on ne peut pas
le définir donc la liberté va être le
moyen de réguler si vous êtes contre le
voile dans l'espace public ou que vous
pensez que le voile est un signe de
soumission de la femme à l'homme
insupportable ok donc vous allez voir la
personne doit les vous l'a convaincu si
vous allez au guichet et qu'il ya
quelqu'un qui vous allez oust qu'à une
kippa sur la tête là c'est plus pareil
vous appelez le directeur et vous dites
donc ça c'est pas la loi la loi c'est la
neige
alors après je suis contre le voile à
l'école j'ai dû bien l'école primaire ou
au collège nous avons affaire à des
mineurs je suis contre le ce qui
s'appelle le voile intégral plus comment
on appelle ça la burqa etc
ce mardi bon c'est un terrien ya des
bruits donc à l'époque c'est la droite
qui a proposé sa moi j'aime me suis
prononcé ces tours la loi c'est même
sens c'était la droite qui le faisait
donc ce n'était pas un sujet de droite
gauche était l'idée qu'on se faisait de
la séparation des églises et de l'état
quelles que soient les églises
voilà ma position alors après il ya vous
savez là encore c'est en gros prétexte
ça ne le dérangeait pas que leur
grand-mère bonne catholique ait eu un
foulard sur la tête et je vois pas
qu'aucun d'entre eux et l'insolence
d'aller dire à sa grand mère si elle met
un foulard sur la tête mais merthyr
pouvait ça parce que c'est pas la loi
alors voulait mettre toujours un petit
atteint enfin quand même ce vote mais
parce que j'essaye de vous cyril hanouna
faut vous rendre compte d'une chose à
quel point ça peut être blessant mais
moi je ne m'en rendais pas compte
moi je ne m'en rendais pas compte à quel
point ça peut être blessant pour une
jeune femme qui porte son foulard pour
ces raisons elle religieuse de
s'entendre dire qu'elle est une pauvre
bourrique soumise à un homme et comme
l'a dit un de mes collègues qui est pas
sur mais bon il a dit ce qui compte
c'est parce qu'elles ont sur la tête
c'est ce qu'elles ont dans la tête
exactement et pardon de vous dire que
les jeunes femmes françaises qui sont de
culture musulmane
les autres qui sont là aussi ah mais
elles ont pas elles n'acceptent pas
qu'on leur donne des ordres elles sont
capables de se révéler si elles ne
veulent pas les appliquer donc un peu de
respect pour les gens personnellement
après à ceux qui veulent me donner des
leçons de théologie je le redis
équipez-vous bien avant de venir me
parler par jean luc mélenchon est vrai
qu'on n'est pas connaisseur désignera un
peu binaire sur le sujet on a
l'impression qu'il y en a certains qui
défendent le fait que toutes les femmes
qui portent le voile le porte de leur
libre arbitre puis de l'autre côté on a
déjà eu le sentiment que toutes les
femmes qui portent le voile sans forcer
à le porter je pense que la vérité mais
quand même un peu plus complet que ça il
faut qu'on aborde la vérité du terrain
est telle qu'elle est ouais les femmes
qui le portent par la liberté de
conscience leur libre oui et je pense
que dans des deux pouces et l'achat
média notre étoile abéché ce choix là il
faut le respecter et bien sûr il ya des
femmes à qui il faut dire bien sûr si à
un moment donné vous êtes chamailler
bousculer oublier oui et donc de le
faire sachez que la république saura
vous protéger alors je pense qu'il faut
passer du discernement mais comment
voulez qu'on est en train de parler là
la clé
vous êtes d'accueillir 300 milles
jusqu'au toit sur la tête 2000 personnes
qui meurent dans la rue et nous de quoi
on parle d'un voile c'est vrai alors
pardon vous dire ce que ça commence à la
blague